shall we
oh
excuse me benton yes what were you just
doing sometimes i have fun that's like
when chelsea land before
chelsea lamb before her tammy character
goes
it's like that
it's like
she's holding a hot dog
like she's
fighting
what did you just do benton is this your
new is this your new on purpose tick
no i just i thought it would be fun no
guys
no
have i ever done anything for fun
yes what universal studios well that was
forced i had to do it to seem fun and
then it became fun
yeah i was i just did it to be like i
hope they think i'm fun i'm going to do
this and hate it and then i happen to
like it
well i guess we know what to do for next
time and i got some jokes out of it so
can you move your hair over that shirt
is beautiful and it's the first time
you're not wearing a madewell
fucking
the least interesting to look at
true cannot stop quoting kim kardashian
yelling at courtney i will i'll quote
anything i hear that say it do the whole
thing
maybe if you had a business you were
fucking passionate about you know what
it takes to run a fucking business but
you don't so you know what you can go
because you're the least interesting to
look at
benton says this all day
while we're touring
like in tsa pre-check line like yells it
is do you remember yesterday when i was
telling you that he is more annoying
than i that's like benton is more
annoying than i am that's what i meant
you're annoying and different depends on
if you're annoyed by fun or not you're
it's it's i don't spend my whole day
oh no do i have toxic shock syndrome oh
no
oh
i need to go to the hospital
i have dust in my uvula
emily was like i think i have leprosy
from the pig bong you know that he was
making fun of you with the toxic shock
syndrome thing not me no you wouldn't
yeah no that was you when did i think i
had tsm you think i have my parents
talking about you and your your many
ailments you have out of nowhere oh it's
so funny you said tss because i really i
i changed my tampons so frequently
there's no way i can get that is that
just how you finger yourself is this how
you masturbate
you just want to get in a little quick
yes that's yeah
only way you can masturbate at work i
feel like you have your no i mean i do
it
was i'm here
what time did i tell this story in the
background i don't know so when i had
coven
i sucked my lover's dick in a closet
and
and like i had not sucked a dick in so
long because i have a house and i just
don't
have to do that anymore and i hadn't
done it in so long but i think i just
had like
really made a lot of mistakes as a
girlfriend and so i was like okay i'm
just gonna like suck this guy's dick
and i like got down and i didn't want to
get on my knees because i have all your
slaughters so i got like like did what
catchers do like i was on my and then i
was like you were a face card i what
i wore a face mask
and a mint and a chest plate
that's how i do it
and uh so i like was down like squatting
and that is hard that sounds terrible
you're teetering like you have to be in
good shape and i was not in good shape
and you'd have to like hold his dick to
like not fall over like that's not what
they like um they like teeth and so then
i'm and then i had to like
move like i had to like move my like to
just like because i was like i'm just
going to get on like side saddle like on
the floor like right yeah just position
you know yeah like a julia armand in
legends of the fall
settle on the horse you know she's
blowing three dudes
yeah on a horse yeah yeah she didn't
mean to pop her head that's the only
thing that would make me suck a guy's
dick
because then you could just keep your
head still because until it ends like
the never-ending story yeah it just does
it for me yeah and then if you're riding
it then you get to you a lot of girls
have orgasms riding horses i'm just
saying a lot of horse girls it's a thing
that's why they're horse girls that's
why you learn about your
anatomy as a young tyke to be fair
during this moment in your life you also
thought that getting a spray tan would
cure your covenant
well there was a little bit i love it i
don't know this story wait finish
the oh that was still going yes yes
when benton hasn't said anything for a
minute and a half he's just decided that
the story has to be he's done wonder
where i learned that he's involved
i thought i better have something to say
you weren't taking on mentorship
so i uh uh so i flip over and i just
hear like a pop like i like i it hurts
so bad i didn't even feel it like
remember when the girl that got her
arm bitten off by a shark said it felt
like an orgasm because you get in so
much pain like when my ear was bitten
off yeah
your body sends um
uh dopamine to the area so that you
don't get so you fight for your life
basically so to be clear for the
listeners you're comparing having your
arm bitten off by a shark to giving a
blowjob
i just want to make sure we're clear on
that
arm
shark
have you given a blow job recently she
said
she said this is sim this is a this is
context don't understand up there
honestly at least i would like you know
be seen as the hero i am
at least the recognition yeah at least
by the way at least getting your arm
bitten off by a shark isn't a job you
said i would have lost both arms and i
would have had to have given the blowjob
but never a hand job again hand job i've
never successfully executed i don't know
how the wetness i don't know like it
always feels too dry and i don't know if
i'm supposed to spit on it is that
disrespectful i don't know if this is
respectful but i and then you have to
gag and then you're crying and you're
like the scanner and your hands are
always full of stitches so that makes it
really hard
so many rings
it's just a sally for the night before
i'm always cutting my cuticles and
they're bleeding so i i just lube it up
in blood and that gets dry and crusty
and
do not get me started on blood
what are you talking about
who's been holding a vendetta against
blood like you the blood banks benton
will just narrate things he sees and i
need to have blinders on that's because
you're never looking up from the phone
so i have to let you know what's going
on around you she's playing best fiends
but benton will just be like uh like
look at that baby over there like in the
fountain about to drown i'm like i can't
we gotta get the flight and he's like
look at that lady like crawling with the
tampon string out i'm like stay focused
like he has to narrate every drama and
chaos that he sees in the airport and i
can't take it on that early i'm i barely
didn't forget my license at the fucking
desk
i do love that do not get me started on
blood do don't don't get me started on
blood right now i can't don't because if
once i start
once i start i'm bleeding out baby blood
broad banks
you're bleeding me dry
the blood's gonna start coming out of
her eyes i'm gonna have a stigmata don't
get me started i'm like 6 38 my favorite
kind of blood don't get me
not that early
it was such a hard boundary
don't don't talk about it so my ankle
pops and i and i tell um and i can't
work out for like months like i have a
like i'm putting menthol gel on it like
during the day multiple times like i
have something wrong but i can't go to
the doctor because i already am like
have coven and it's just like there's
they won't let you come in
were you i made the delta strain yeah
i'd already fallen on the table in the
middle of night i was just like nah i
was just like i can't i don't have time
for this to hurt it would be a problem
so i just ignored it and wore like wedge
sneakers
i just wore like boots that i thought
would hold them in i was like i was just
wearing boots and i would tie real tight
just be like this is she just put two
sticks on her ankle and tied a bandana
around it i'm just forced gump like just
didn't like braces
and so i just have like leg work she
started walking with a stick
i just became a bed lady like i just
became like a couch i just laid on the
couch all day and watched the crown but
i don't remember any of it um
because it just was too boring yeah why
are you guys pretending like that's a
good show you're watching the crown and
you kept going this is about england
like every episode she was very sick and
on a lot of people i know i was like why
are we pretending this is it's a great
show
if you're gay
and or trying to figure out your sexual
like there's no way
it's not as
good
as we think well your lover really liked
that
well also great i only date gay men
great dreams you don't know it right
away great transition because this oh
but the end of that story is whitney was
telling the story about bringing your
ankle and giving a blowjob in the closet
to another person and i overheard it and
said was i there
emily the only thing i was like i
destroyed a ligament giving a blowjob in
the closet she's like was i there
was that in the other room
like who cares like as if
you're
you have bad karma with god
you know you worked at snl do you know
how many blow jobs were given in closets
near you
jesus that's why i like to be aware i
know not even good ones like ben has
been there three times
i've been at once but speaking of the
crown our guest today
is british himself
oh wow jack whitehall awesome and by the
way
hot as shit i've given blow jobs and
closets and that made me uncomfortable
oh i just fucked my tooth on here
is it just i've been in the closet and
i'm gonna go back and hear
that bench and i have a hard time
leaving you ever in the closet i wasn't
but that was a good joke
that was a good thing you were maybe you
were in a dress bar hit me
you were inviting me you were watching
veronica's closet
veronica
all right let's talk about the dates
i'm gonna be in san diego january 7th
2022 balboa theater it has actually
always been my dream to do the balboa
theater i've always done the american
comedy club company i'm sorry
and the uh
american comedy club i'm sorry and la
jolla comedy club in san diego i am now
doing balboa theater cannot wait san
diego come on
conservatives welcome also surfers let's
go
1 8 22 january 8th i'm in salt lake city
at kingsbury hall
i've always done wise guys and we're
going to do comedy in a hall whoa um
i'm going to be in vegas oh january 15th
that's right where i'm at the win las
vegas
win
steve wynn who as you know oh we lost an
assistant who only pushes his cups back
on the table that pusher when he
like gets it right on teetering on the
edge we should include that he's going
blind that's why he does that correct
and thank god because he's part of the
check he's writing me he'd really be
pissed
and so
uh when did we talk about that what
episode did we talk about steve went in
he did it in an open um recently
recently
why the one that came out with who just
if you guys want to know the see i talk
about steve wynn for about 20 minutes
last week
i'm worried you asked pat a lot of
questions
that are my job all right if i put you
on the spot you're gonna be like would
you put me on the spot i've never said
that to you in my entire life i'm not
wearing my striped shirt that keeps me
powerful and focused
i'm off brown i'm wearing this nice
shirt
she's calling it a nice shirt because
it's her shirt on the 28th of january
we're coming to nashville january is a
big month for the haha
and uh we're going to be at the carolina
theater last time i was in north
carolina i think we were at the carrie
improv which is gorgeous but we're going
bigger we're going bigger and you're
coming it's going to be an elegant
theater at the end of the shows we
always do a meet and greet for free we
don't charge you for meet and greets
because we're not
sick
and no one would pay and
we tried and no no we gotta
no one added to carter if you want to
leave a cash tip when you that's fine
too we'll leave a bowl hit our event
we'll have our vendor up on the screen
behind us
or the same six fans that come to every
show can bring me more her shirts which
is fine too but we will do selfies with
you after the show we sit up on stage
benton and i uh have a if you want me to
make uh videos for your dead sister no i
would really be careful because benton
will not hear you because he's doing
bits and then he'll be like you'll be
like hey can you make a video for my
sister she passed away two years ago and
ben who goes
what is she dead
doing bits i was talking to other fans
and when i looked back whitney had a
snapchat photo with a ponytail on
because so i didn't know that she was
making a serious video in a ponytail and
lashes snapchat and i went she went hey
can you make a video for my dad's sister
what does that mean
like just to say like thank you emily so
she said can you please make a video for
my dead sister and just say rest in
paradise like margaret and all i heard
and then it was a snapchat and i don't
know snapchat so i picked it up and then
i was then i had purple hair and then
she was like the baby face yeah the dog
ears yeah or what if you did like
grim reaper
and so when i turned back around she's
in a snapchat photo going rest in
paradise and i went is she dead
and then and the girl was like yes and i
was like oh my god and we're with rosa
baker whose sister died and she thought
it was really funny christ
and she was like is she dead and the
girl's like yeah my sister died and i
was like oh no oh no
oh this is called
this video and i was like how do i get
this fucking filter where i like have
like sexy eyes wide shut mask
i know so that i can make it you're like
a barratt's dog you're like
i was like
you're like why is it snowing on this
filter like fuck why do i look like a
powder puff girl this is a nightmare
like what have cat ears and they have
nine lives and shit
she wishes i feel like i'm mocking your
dead sister so yeah so we
don't ask me to make videos for your
dead sister because we just we're not in
that headspace um but we love you enjoy
jack whitehall jack whitehall is the
star of the clifford movie which is out
right now kills on the jonas brothers
roast which is on netflix right now he
was in jungle cruise he had that show
he's got
i must say my favorite show on tv is so
travels with my father it is the most
funny heartwarming show dead serious i
like i i re-watch it and he's a dream
phenomenal phenomenal and he's by the
way he was amazing you weren't here
benton he wasn't this interesting i love
him this interview was like one of my
favorites don't you think it was really
good do you think yeah i'm looking i was
kind of in love with him and it was like
i was like because i am so obsessed with
his show that i'm like a legitimate fan
yeah and was like really geeking out on
him and he's just oh yeah you played it
cool anything yeah i tried yeah it was
good i had wine you're pretty cool yeah
you're pretty cool thanks
oh we'll take it back then you stuck
enjoying paradise enjoy jack whitehall
[Music]
a beer or something
no no i i i wasn't gonna say i'm driving
i can't drive no i even
was gonna lie that i could drive and you
got me a guy so you know that's a lie
no i just don't know
maybe you want a drink
i think i'm still a little jet-lagged
okay
that's a weird way of saying nervous
where
brian moses is comedy roast i didn't
even know who the other people are
judging and they're going to be coming
at me and i don't have any information
about any of them i'm going completely
ill-prepared i can help you well i'm
going to be a lamb to the slaughter wait
no have you so the jonas rose did you
you you you've done rose before
uh
yeah that's how we talk to each other no
we tend to do it behind each other's
backs that's right
right yes we won't um insult someone to
their face we'll just call them a cum
behind their back
um but i have done the roast once before
because they try to launch roasts in the
uk about eight years ago with jimmy carr
and we did a load of them but the
problem is with all of these things in
england is if you try and do
roasts or you try and do saturday and
live you simply can't get the quality of
guests so we were roasting a load of
people that were very much like not even
on the way down but they were like
rock bottom and it felt like such
punching down it's only fun if honestly
like because the big ones that i did the
first one i did was joan rivers and no
one had heard of me so i was able to go
so
hard yeah i literally opened with joan i
loved you and the wrestler yeah like i
was eight but if i was no one else could
have said that to her only a nobody who
obviously didn't have health insurance
and who was like you know cried in her
car if she'd had one and um and so and
then it was david hasselhoff and then i
did trump and by the time i did trump i
was like no i i it stopped being as good
because it was like
like punching down to people i was like
going after larry king i was like let's
get through this roast before larry king
dies like it was just like everyone was
like he's gonna die
like it just didn't feel right you're
exactly right that's like the uk roasts
were that it was a load of people who
you you like most of them you thought
were dead and it was that there was the
big shot was that they were not only
still alive but back on television for
the first time no they need the money
and yes and that was it as well it was
literally just so that they could um you
know get a check and it was all just a
bit tawdry um so that was my only
experience of having done them before
are there any good roast jokes that you
remember about you
about me um
no nothing's better when a comedian
that
you know is just sparring with you comes
at you with the most brutal rose joke on
the planet like
nick schwartzen
nick swartz and the other day we were
shooting something together
and i had just gotten this like
like laser thing like a laser whatever
i'm 39 years old i'm like everyone
thought i got a face lift 10 years ago
so i'm like
you know fuck it thank you
um i've always looked like i had plastic
surgery even when i was a baby i'll show
you baby pictures i mean it looks like i
have filler in my face it's wild maybe
they did that i don't know so i my face
was like swollen and i had kind of had
bruising so the makeup artist like put
like
contouring like and like it was my face
was like swollen and we were just like
going back and forth and you just went
why are you wearing a halloween mask
because it's like first of all there's
no such thing as a halloween mask
there's like wolverine there's
freddy krueger like it's just
he met the ones from like the 40s it was
just general halloween just scary like
just a scary like face that looks melty
it has like a string like a rubber band
and then um
he was on the podcast yesterday and he
goes i was like i interrupted him he was
talking he's like can you not interrupt
me i'm like well can you talk faster and
he goes sorry i'm not an adderall
mannequin
like nothing is better
than being able to like be made fun of
it and not be and it'd be funny enough
to undo how mean it is yeah but if i'd
known that then i probably would have
come to this again more prepared with a
load of slights that i could sling in
your direction but i didn't know that
that was going to be the nature of the
discussion i think you should just more
go after just america and american
comedy like the idea of like
if brian moses comes at you or some
random open micro comes at you i wish i
knew who was going to be coming at me
well if they're just like because
whatever
you know it's not going to be funny
um but you can just be like
you know
i feel like sorry now i'm writing bro
strokes should probably roast people
that i know and like frankly um but uh
you can just do like oh you know what
i'm not gonna come back at you because
frankly the only reason you're here is
because you're the only comedian in l.a
that hasn't shown their dick it's like
you're not funny you just haven't raped
anyone so
i'm saying like i feel like there's a
way to just
or
you're so unfunny that nobody cares that
you did yeah no one even tried to cancel
you no i'm concerned you're not famous
enough just because of your anonymity
yeah totally yeah like no one like no
one can remember your name yeah to like
call ronan pharaoh
okay well that's that's enough
ammunition i think okay i mean i feel
like i'm probably gonna be alarmed to
the slaughter i can't imagine that's
going to be particularly helpful
with the big red dog i imagine that
would be quite good awesome just be like
yeah no make fun i mean look i i'll just
make fun of my million dollar green
screen movie where i didn't where i just
got to
like what dude you're my dan levy a
friend of mine not dan levy the other
one dan levy comedian i was talking to
him last night and he's like i was
talking to his daughter who's like a
legitimate friend of mine she's seven
and she's like i have to go i'm watching
clifford and dan was like jack is
legitimately hilarious in this movie
oh that's that's nice which no one can
do i love the rock but the tooth fairy
didn't go great
you know what i'm saying it's hard for
funny people to be funny in kids movies
yeah
it is hard it's also hard like
recalibrating your whole kind of
like stick and
trying to improvise when you know that
like so much of it huge sways of what
you're gonna say we'll never see the
light of day and also to like
not stop that from like making you do it
and try stuff and like so many times i
was just like why am i even doing this
because there's absolutely no way on
earth this is ever going to see the
light of day
but i guess just like getting over that
mentality and just going well you've got
to just throw enough shit at the wall
and something is going to stay
like more so than anything else really
in terms of you doing movies no no no
like if you're in a kids film or a
family film or in those family films
just got to just like throw so much
stuff like i just did clifford to see
what like just if see ninopa would see
the light of day like
no i mean like i'm like trying to be
funny in those films uh yes and totally
you're like
censoring from the get-go and going
right i need to just improvise in a
family-friendly way it's like so much of
the stuff that i did in that film
um
you know
was obviously never going to end up in
there but you're always surprised by
like what they what you can smuggle in
like you've got a burning man joke into
it i say bollocks in the film which they
try to get me to replace or and i
thought they had replaced it i went in
to do like bollocks just means shit
bollocks means testicles i mean it's a
swear word bollocks oh balls it's like
being like
no but it's worse than balls like
bollocks is a legitimate swear word only
in england though in england yeah not in
america they could just take it out in
england and not anywhere else i think
that's what they might do but it's still
in the american version no really
yeah
i said bollocks and then like right cut
him out completely
it's just the dog in england's like what
happened to jack whitehall's career
yeah i still don't know the accents the
posh versus the all of it you can't hear
an accent
you wouldn't be able to hear the
difference between
like posh person and the working class
person from i think it's the a's and the
r's and the r's so you think you the r's
are you don't see the r's yeah and then
the a's are longer yeah
right yeah we just over pronounce
i to be fair when i first started doing
stand-up
um didn't like the fact that i sounded
posh and felt like if i was going into
clubs i would need to change my voice so
for the first like four or five years of
my career oh yeah that's what i should
have done it's just gone
no i wanted people not to hate me so
american would not have helped in that
environment
and i tried to hide the fact that i went
to a boarding school and all of my jokes
were so inauthentic the whole act was
ridiculous i came on in like a parker
looking like one of oasis and like
mumbled up one of my jokes and it was
just that and i watch it back now and
it's just it's skin crawling and also
because i started very young i ended up
on tv quite quickly so it was also it's
all like committed to film so it's you
know every now and again like it'll
appear on some repeat on the bbc and my
twitter will just explode going what the
fuck was this hey madonna what the fuck
is that accent
it's a madonna
working class
so funny to me we all i mean my early
stand up was just like rape joke rape
jokers i mean it's just but netflix
bought my first special which was like
on comedy central 10. your first special
you just like it stuck your sex tape
yeah it's like i don't want anyone to
see it it served its purpose you're like
learning how to do stand-up on tv it's
me just like yelling about anal sex like
screaming i had a similar style though
quite shouty i don't think i've ever
shaken that off i watched them like oh
my god
i'm a woman though i'm shrill men are
we're not designed to really want to
hear a woman talk or complain for 45
minutes
yeah you know what i mean
i said yeah like that yeah right
i mean you know i'm right i mean you
know okay i need to talk to you because
i we kind of jumped into this and i feel
like i know you really well and i don't
at all i usually start the podcast
asking are we friends and then you get
to say it
in what respect and like are we i don't
like going on podcasts that have people
that i don't really know and they're
like my good friend whitney's here and
i'm like i don't know you and now this
is weird because i have to
we're sort of casual acquaintances we we
were going to work together once that's
how we first met that's right i'm ready
to put you in the museum
who we've never heard of since
he is philadelphia
he's great some show and
like shyamalan show in philadelphia or
something no you were like i remember
doing fucking some movie about dragons
in ireland or something
this was when you were just like doing
massive movies you just you it was like
right like you obviously had the uh your
uh uh show
on in england and then you started doing
like studio movies i remember because
you had the same agent at the time steve
smith and he was like no way and i'm
like i got james marsden like i got you
know all the cat tannings i got annie
feldstein i got like it's four days of
work and it was like he's doing some
giant movie yeah
that was the and that was offer and you
had been working with brett my friend
brett goldstein yes yeah he played my
voice
he played my boyfriend in my hbo pilot
yeah
that that was the other connection but
yeah so i want to talk to you because i
am like a
very big fan of yours
and you are a very big part of my life
and i am sorry about that because this
is gonna get you don't deserve this okay
when my dad died i started watching your
show he sent me a lovely message
and oh my gosh i'm literally gonna cry
and it like got me through it oh thank
you so much
like i truly just decided that your dad
is my dad like i went into a total
um
dysphoria and like disassociative state
where i just pretended your dad was my
dad and that we were a family
i know it's psychotic and crazy but i
totally just did
i'm obsessed with your dad he's my
mr rogers yeah i
i cannot get enough of him like watching
you guys together and i feel like i
never had a family that was like
healthy with each other i'm so
embarrassed and i'm crying no no no i
love that that that's i know you made
that connection with me
yeah
so this is imaginable no no no it's
amazing that you have that connection
with the show i remember you've sent an
incredible message which i've remembered
now and
and it's like you know to make a show
like this which is so you know
so much of it is so dumb and silly and
and playful but you know to have
people connect to it in that way is like
incredible it like
you know
i do try and
uh as much as i can with that with that
show like show our relationship and and
try to you know make it something more
than just a you know
stupid
uh comedy travel log and which is not
like because but it's also so
educational it's also like actually
you're
you know i'm i don't know why i'm just
randomly burning bridges here but like
anthony bourdain i love i know we're not
allowed to say anything negative about
him even though kevin nealon has the
funniest anthony bourdain joke on the
planet he's just like anthony vernon
he's like i didn't get it
he literally did it like two weeks after
he died like can we stop pretending he's
entertaining which like i do anthony
bourdain like i really i i love a travel
show we never i travel all the time in
america i mean 50 cities a year we
travel but i never get to see anywhere
so it's like i rely on travel shows to
actually see the places i go for one
night and never get to and then i can
sort of like vicariously act like i
actually got to experience it yeah but
anthony never seemed
like i mean now we know that he
obviously was struggling with a lot of
mental demons but he i i never felt like
he was that psyched to be in these
amazing places yeah he would like they
would make him some
like
seven day aged roast pig that was and he
just like looks good and it was just
like so like he just wanted to get out
of there you know and you like have such
a good time and it's so
i don't like i really don't watch any
reality stuff like it makes me
uncomfortable it makes me cringe because
people feel like it feels forced like it
is such a breath of fresh air and it's
so it's most comedy makes you feel dirty
afterwards because it like hurts someone
or whatever yeah and i but you fuck up
my the one now i'm mad at you
because the
i sort of hang on to the thing of like
you have to have had damage to be funny
yeah you have to be fucked up to be
funny yeah and you don't
i mean you you're you're coming for your
loving family i mean the doll winston's
weird yes so that counts as child of you
so maybe that's it maybe that's the
truth yeah okay guys that was the
darkness yeah that's it and in years to
come it will because i'm just always
curious because i'm like the stereotype
is all comedians come from
yeah something fucked up our lack of
love and like and you were loved but
maybe that makes even more sense because
you're free to play and you're not
behaving out of fear and like developing
negative coping mechanisms yeah but my
comedy i would say probably reflects
that like the criticism that i guess has
probably been leveled at me is that when
i go up on stage i'm probably not as
introspective as i could be
and who wants to go to a comedy show and
like critics
yeah they don't go to comedy shows they
are called critics that's why they're
looking for somebody to criticize my
favorite uh oscar wilde quote i think
it's him he's attributed a lot of quotes
yeah and we don't have i mean he has to
be like knocking out i feel like he was
plenty of quotes today he must have been
a nightmare to be around i feel like he
hurt no because someone else probably
said him and he probably you know mean
oh yeah yeah who says who was what was
the plagiarism i don't i just don't buy
that all of those are his
i don't buy it like i just i i'm here to
say that i feel like
he probably said he said them all yeah
but who is going to be he's going to
call him out on that prove me wrong yeah
how do you know you're right stephen
fry's going to be coming for you who's
that
well
who's stephen fry just
you'd have been great in the age of
twitter oscar wilde wouldn't he uh yes
so would um uh
mitch hedberg yeah oh my god yes and you
know who'd be great in the time of tick
tock charlie chaplin
yeah he would he would be great
he was really born at the wrong time
you know like that's fascinating to me
okay and i want to get i want to get
back to a couple things because uh also
the show is
as someone that like really cannot enjoy
television or movies because i'm like
that was
adr like that was looping like that was
they did use the same code twice like
that one you know what i mean yeah it's
that was out of focus like if you've
seen under the bonnet it is beautiful
that show thank you it is beautifully
edited yeah they've they really make it
look
very good for what it is it's like it
looks like a studio movie and i don't
know it's honestly like the tiniest crew
of people it's such a small group of
people that do it and i also don't know
how the fuck you get half the shots
you're hanging off of a cliff
in a sack yeah
and it's like not particularly big
budget there's a tiny skeleton crew my
dad works like 80 year old man hours so
we have to
start at 10 and finish by four every day
and he has to break for an hour uh at
lunch and have wine otherwise he won't
film so we're only shooting a couple of
hours a day we're the same person yes
although i don't know whether daddy
would like june shine this is wine
that's wine yeah
that's fine
and then let me ask you what are some
destinations that you wanted to do but
didn't like it didn't work out for
whatever reason um i would have really
liked to go to south america
um japan
i've been to japan before so i would
have loved to have got him out to japan
but then by the end he wasn't really
willing to travel hence why we did one
round the uk
which was not really traveling with my
father because that was kind of more the
uh that was like the um
winston churchill yeah it's so funny
yeah with him in the back there's this
there's this scene where they're in
winston churchill's house
and he loves winston churchill like his
dad and um
he they go into his bathroom and he's
got like a sunken bathtub which is so
funny and weird and your dad is like i
don't want to go in his bat like it is
so awkward and it's just so stupid my
lady was very strict as well and i was
trying to get him into winston
churchill's bed and he was like i don't
want to go in there and she was like
well you can't go in there anyway you
were like can uh he go in there and she
went no like it was like i don't care
how many cameras are here how much money
this guy like absolutely not they're
really straight oh my god the best thing
happened on that day they got edited out
completely from the show
and i had decided when we went around
winston churchill's house that as a
surprise i was going to book a winston
churchill look alike to turn up at the
end and my dad was going to get a load
of photos with this winston churchill
look alike so i said to the producers
just find me a winston church or look at
like get him down to the nashville
house
so he comes along and we have to do it
all outside in the garden and it was a
bit weird they didn't really tell me why
and anyway it was a terrible scene that
ended up not making it into the edit
because it was just weird and my dad was
like who is this man
he looked a bit like winston churchill
it was basically just a fat man with a
cigar and when he opened his mouth his
throat it was like all right my ear my
name's dane yeah i'll do this full time
and he would like he didn't my dad was
like well he suddenly hasn't nailed the
voice
dad a famous talent agent by the way
it was yeah it was it was it was a very
strange scene but then the best um
detail emerged afterwards which was the
reason that we weren't allowed to shoot
it actually on the grounds of the house
is because this man who is a
professional winston churchill look
alike has been banned from winston
churchill's house because he turns up in
the full costume and wanders around
trying to get selfies with people and
like just touts his trade at winston
churchill's actual house and the
national transit had to ban him from the
premises they might say you've got to
stop turning up here and we brought him
along and he's like persona non crotch
how weird is that i am so sorry that we
have to take a break from the
charming relentless violently charming
jack whitehole
like the i having to like listen i feel
like it's it's borderline abusive
to
have someone
enjoy the caramelly molasses english
accent of uh
for an hour and then have to go to just
us
we're sorry so can someone do anything
can you guys just should we just do
english absolutely
thank you
no yours is very different mine's very
cockney no i know i know mine's very
bang-up but it's more more posh one yeah
see that's what we just talked about
that about the po okay so you're posh
you're
a scullery
okay wow you don't like that part of
england
um okay here's my deal absolutely vibes
remember when i pitched the way to save
the environment is no bubble wrap yes if
you want something fragile you have to
buy it in person yep so
i'm obsessed with shipping
that's my new cause it's my new thing
that i just i think about a lot so i'm
obsessed with buying things online i
have 500 packages at my house at all
times uh from uh
you know etsy to i don't want to name
all of it
am i allowed to name the places
anyway i want your crafts i want your
hearts and i want your crib she's
passionate about and i want them now
yeah okay i finally got a macaroni frame
i've won
one of you you ever put glue down on a
cookie sheet make snowflakes send it my
way i want it i'm adding it to my cart
and since we love you and your craft so
much we want to tell you about a way to
make your life easier get your crafts to
me yes so if you like selling crafts
online or have a deep burning love for
logistics and order or money or if
you're like me and you want to stop
standing in line places to mail 12 boxes
to your mom
then you can just get ship stationed and
do all those labels at your house drop
them right off at the post office
because
no matter how you sell your goods to
whitney shopify etsy your own website
shipstation funnels all your orders into
one simple interface that you can manage
from anywhere even your cell phone wild
ship more in less time and for a lot
less money i don't have time to wait for
your
vintage
macrame sex toy we need it now
get your ship together so we can get our
stuff faster
and just use whitney's offer code
whitney to get a 60 day free trial
that's two months free of no hassle
stress free shipping you're welcome
everyone just go to shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the page and type in whitney that
shipstation.com enter offer code whitney
make ship happen okay emily i know that
we both have a lot of student loans
and i am finally in a place where i can
help other people that's amazing and so
this is what i got you oh my god you
remembered my half birthday
you got me a comment i'm like you dad
this is oh no i didn't get your computer
this is just uh this is earnest you can
sign up and they'll help you save on
your student loans that's what i meant
by help you
oh you just pulled up the website on a
computer you're not giving me they put a
christmas bag on it
yeah that's being kind yeah i agree hard
agree and it unwrapped it for you so
that's extra kind of that no that is
typical that's very thoughtful and i
can't afford a computer because of all
my student loans but it's great to be
able to use yours for yeah you should
consider refinancing all your federal
student loans with earnest like i did
are they federal what are good what
federal did you go to did you go to the
government jail for
private school
you learned a lot more in jail than you
would in college that you paid for you
really should consider refinancing your
federal student loans with earnest and
of course make sure to review the cares
act disclosure carefully first i've
heard that ernest is the number one
student loan refinancer in the country
you heard it
from who on this podcast
has told me was that written on there
are you better now they are in the top
this is where you talk about a party
it's your student loans jesus you
probably do um i would just like to
point out that whitney is digging into
her toenails in a feather
robe
i am wearing and i'm getting feedback
i'm
hey it looks like we just pulled you out
of the institution to be here with that
it looks like we had to sign a couple
forms to get you out
and we have to get you back in before
nightfall it looks like you've escaped
and they're looking for the chicken
under your bed bitch
ernest is our number one student loan
refinancer in the country they are in
the top spot by helping thousands of
people get better rates lower their
monthly payments or helping or by
helping their customers combine multiple
loans into a simple monthly payment and
earnest doesn't charge an i'm sorry and
ernest doesn't charge any fees ever not
even late fees right now earnest is
offering our listeners a hundred dollar
cash bonus refinance your student debt
at earnest.com whitney not available in
all states once again you get a 100 cash
bonus when you visit earnest.com whitney
to refinance your student loan do you
want to look up from your cuticles and
read some of the copy here visit
earnest.com whitney for it's not my
cuticles did you want this check to
clear or not look up it's an ingrown
toenail visit earnest.com whitney for
more details not available in all states
term the conditions apply earnest
student loan refinancing made by earnest
operations llc nmls number one two zero
four nine one seven california financing
law license number six zero five four
seven eight five three five mission
street san francisco california nine
four one zero five visit earnest.com
licensed assistances for a full list of
licenses
that was amazing i'd clap but
now back to
jack whitehall
you know what this is actually an idea
that you could do one day
i've had this idea for a movie which
i've like sold it a billion times and
bought it back because it's it's it's
incredibly talent specific yeah and you
ha and i've had a couple like really big
actors attached to it i think nick cage
was like he was that was like the goal
like for the longest time but
it's about a celebrity impersonator who
the celebrity that they impersonate has
a very public meltdown like a la charlie
sheen yeah and uh you know he's like
this this celebrity impersonator is like
in orlando he's like making 80 grand a
year like gets the best table at
applebee's like like
it gets paid at the opening the car
dealership birthday parties but mitzvahs
like gets chicks like his life is great
because he's like the tom cruise
impersonator you know and then let's say
tom cruise has a very public meltdown
that would never happen um or uh and
then uh goes full like charlie sheen
yeah tiger blood fuck this like like
hooker's in the house loses you know if
it's brad pitt and angelina i know
they're broken up but like loses the
girl whatever yeah and then uh it has
like prostitutes in the house porn stars
like a nightmare
and so this guy loses all his bookings
and like he's not only that he's like
walking down the street and people like
hey fuck you man like he's like totally
it's like destroyed his not only his
life he has no other skills yeah he's
been impersonating this guy for 20 years
you know like say jack nicholson in
person or something and then so he
decides to go to la and find him and
help him get his life back together so
that he can have his like life back yeah
yeah and uses all the guys movies to be
like
where they're where they can't take our
lives but they can't take our freedom
you said that you know like is trying to
get him back yeah you know get him sober
and through him and stuff like that and
uh
and then
and the the nicholas cage plays both
parts amazing so now there is the
technology available they did an orphan
black where you can like fight with
yourself and you can hit yourself and
stuff so you have to be you know one
actor like gaining some weight yeah just
being slightly different yeah and i we
figured out how to shoot it um it's a
great idea i know
because this does happen as well like
i've been on celebrity look-alike
websites and seen
in england we have a couple of people
that have obviously been cancelled ralph
harris is a very famous one he was an
entertainer who was cancelled for um
being a sort of perv
and there was a couple of rolf harris
entertainers that have had like
75 80 years of just well not they
probably weren't doing it when he was a
child because i didn't think he was
famous then but they've had a good 50
years of like reaping the rewards of
looking at ralph harris and then all of
a sudden you
hit 75 and you have to pivot because
the guy you're impersonating is a
pedophile so there must be bill cosby
impersonators out there that's exactly
what i mean so it happened to me when
the mel gibson thing happened where he
was like on the freeway drunk like
saying anti-semitic stuff he's fine he
has 12 moves in production yeah and you
could also as a mel gibson look like
probably still get a bit of work you
could maybe be one of the characters and
just commit to being friends not me
that's a professional looking like
that's a woman that lives in portland
who's a pilates instructor and she she
does impersonations of you no but now
she like
like we do dumb videos and shit together
so you shouldn't get cancelled because
it would be hard for her that's the
thing i literally don't do blackface
just because i don't want to ruin her
life yeah like it's my favorite thing to
do
and you would but for her sake i yes i
mean i do and i have already opened up
about this and i'm ready to post the
picture if any of my friends are getting
unfairly cancelled
uh i'm gonna post this picture to try to
like distract and take more like like
jump on the that's the
bullet because there is a picture of me
from i didn't know i was 20. i had just
seen miss saigon and i loved it
and i wore white geisha makeup and a
kimono that i found a thrift store and i
did it it's not ideal but i think you're
probably not like full-on canceled i
just think if your heart is in the right
place like you know me by now do you
know what i mean like you know my heart
um but yeah so so that idea i remember
uh uh when i was at i was like talking
to ca about it
and um i told the story and i was like
it has to be a celebrity
that
is also going to play the impersonator
it's going to play themselves and they
also have to be cool with referencing
their own movies you know so it has to
be written specifically like i have the
outline written but i just has to be
specific yeah yeah yeah if it was
clifford the big red dog he has to come
in with the you know what i mean there's
no point in writing it yeah without all
the specific references
and um uh it would almost just be like
this like an autobiography and like a
celebration of their career and their
failures and everything in a way to like
take the piss out of yourself and like
roast yourself yeah tom middleton does
an impression of robert de niro to
robert de niro on the graham norton show
and it's kind of excruciating why is
that show so
fucking good because they're all at the
same time and they're all drunk was
graham not a comedian he was a stand-up
comedian the other thing that i would
say that is a testament to him and the
reason that shows so good is because
they only do one a week and he does like
a run of like
20 of them and then he has a break and
goes away and writes a book and goes on
holiday and then comes back so he truly
has like gratitude for what he's doing
and it's never like burned out yeah for
all of those late-night hosts here it's
like i mean i know you know to get out
the tiny violins they're getting paid a
lot of money but it is like relentless
that amount of shows and to have to be
on for every single one of them and to
make every single one of them good like
must be pretty fucking hard yeah and i
think that like here also and this is
why podcasts are doing better than late
night shows now is that you're also
interviewing people that you don't know
or particularly like or people that
aren't like you kind of are just like
great i'm interviewing like
you know barry manilow is he alive and
like you know what i mean and carrot top
like i don't know you guys like we
didn't you know what i mean it's just
kind of like and you have seven minutes
yeah and most people are not comedians
like gerard butler isn't getting seven
minutes yeah i've been on shows with
them whatever love you baby love you
love to date you i'm a veil tech avail
but uh
he's not gonna like crush with a seven
minute story he's like telling a story
and then you're sitting next to him like
and and you have to you know and then as
a comedian you're just like we're
bombing we're bombing like i've got like
this is not a pen and teller situation
like i got a date you know and then it
just get you feel like you're it's just
it's just not enough time to
have any kind of nuanced conversation i
feel like but but if you gave them all
wine and you put barry manilow carrot
top and jerry butler on a sofa together
on a friday night buy 50 episodes right
now yeah no you don't have 50 episodes
this is the other thing you're only
allowed one episode
what a week no the american no that's
the american mentality oh it's good we
need 50 of them you've been to the
cheesecake
factory i've never you don't get it i
know faulty towers did six episodes
quantity here quality it's not hard do
less episodes of things make less of it
make it good and make less of them you
know what
everything gets boring after a while i
don't have this house because i've made
less of them
i made more mediocre ones yeah that's
true you get a bigger house okay you get
a bigger house because you syndication
you had to get to 88. and here's the
difference is that english comedian or
english actors don't get paid a ton like
it's not a job like here show runners
get paid 50 000 an episode so you're
like i want to do 20 episodes right
whereas in england like acting isn't you
don't you do now obviously it's
different but like
i just mean like the average exact the
average like tv actor
isn't treated like they're
the only person that was ever be able to
say sentence on they're not making 20
million dollars a week like grey's
anatomy no no that's true why make more
if you're not getting paid more yeah
yeah exactly and in britain it's just no
money i remember like faulty towers but
that that's my only problem with shows
like that like brass i was my favorite
show ever made amazing but then you're
like there's only four yeah
fuck you yeah but imagine faulty towers
episode 50.
how bad that would be doing that same
manual joke for the 50th i don't know i
feel like
maybe
maybe maybe but also yeah small doses is
the key also yeah i mean black mirror
like
if he was doing 30
but yes and then the other thing i guess
is also like the amount of writers that
you have on shows here which does help
keep them fresh and keep the quality
high whereas in the uk it's quite rare
to have a writer's room like no it's so
strange like so many shows don't have a
writer's room and they have started to
the past kind of like five ten years a
lot of times that i mean breaking bad
all the great shows like it's a singular
vision madman shows like that i mean
vincent gilligan gilliam am i saying
right
gilliam
i was thinking about terry gilliam
because i was we were talking about lost
in la mancha the other day have you seen
this documentary
it's like 15 years old and it's a
documentary about terry gilliam trying
to make don quixote yeah yeah and it was
just a behind-the-scenes crew like
documenting it yeah and everything that
could go wrong went wrong like it's so
funny i mean it's tragic like and he's
made it now though hasn't he
with jonathan uh price and adam driver i
don't know yeah i think he did that's
wild he he had like like the main actor
that was playing johnny depp
johnny depp was in the in this
documentary i think he's been attached
to it yeah for a while and um
the uh johnny depp could be good for the
look-alike one
hide it here first test idea manifest it
i might just need to
pay his taxes um but uh
that's an amazing idea you know who else
could be amazing is madonna
um is that a weird one yeah that is a
weird one but it works you think no and
then you go hmm like someone weird like
i mean someone like like
like it's like whitney houston the
bodyguard like lady gaga whitney it's
like has to be something oh sorry i
thought you were suggesting her i was
like oh god am i gonna be the
you see how small my one
was that's on purpose i have some
terrible news you may have been in this
podcast studio for quite some time now
i'm the number one google whitney yeah
i was number two for a while
are there any other whitneys port
whitney port was on um she was on like
an american show about a beach like a
reality show i have jack white who's
quite irritating in terms of
having a name that's close to me the guy
from the white stripes love him no he's
great he's amazing but i think i
disappoint people when they get us
confused no no one's ever done it like
turned up to a gig expecting to see the
white stripes and then be like oh god i
feel like i look at your career and i'm
just like this is so perfectly
it's such a perfect career despite steve
smoot's involvement
and i
just am so blown away by how smart your
choices are are you gonna like now be
like i'm in all these huge movies and
now i need to like play a holocaust
survivor in a drama
like do you have to do that you don't
no i did read through
before i read for seriously
why i wrote for a serial killer this one
it didn't feel right no one i was even
doing
no one's buying most
actors serial killers you have no chance
what are you like you know what i'm
saying
for most actors that's a documentary
yeah
so but why like do you have this thing
where you're like i'm thought of as like
i'm really really funny everybody loves
me now i have to do like whatever the
robin williams
one hour photo maybe i actually on
clifford spoke to john cleese who was in
it and asked him about that i was like
did you have a very victimized
amazing
fan not a fan no my hero oh yeah hero
yeah yeah so he's and i asked him about
that i was like did you not ever want to
go off and and do more like serious
false he was like yeah i did every
10 years i would go i need to go and do
something some proper acting and i would
do it and i was full to tears every time
and i was like i just like making people
laugh so i think i'll probably do that
i'll go off and i'll do one of those
things and i'll be like oh my god this
is so boring i want to make people laugh
and i want to
go and um be urinated on by a 10-foot
cgi red dog i was much happier in that
space
than i am
did not know where that was going
playing serial killers and holocaust
survivors yeah like i just don't it's
also like the set of dramas are so
everyone is so like thinks they're like
curing cancer you know what i mean
everyone thinks like
it's you're just like you guys we're
puppets yeah let's just take it easy
here yeah
yeah like what are we doing because you
can also you can get that with comedy if
you do something that you know is able
to make them laugh and then also maybe
move them and maybe if you were more
introspective on stage you wouldn't have
this hankering get some people crying
that is so dumb no um but uh that's
ridiculous that drives me nuts your
comedy's too funny i want to think more
no one that is the most elitist shit to
say most people
do not like their jobs they're in
cubicles all day they don't want to pay
money to go see jack whitehall and have
him be like let's talk about toxic
masculinity it's like can you just make
a fart joke please i'm poor plenty of
them part of the reason i love english
comedy so much it comes more from like
an insecure self-deprecating well that
it's almost become like it's cliche to
talk about it because every comic that
goes over to america and does gigs comes
back to england and talks about this on
stage which is it's so alien for us to
go into a comedy club and be asked what
our credits are and to be asked by
compare what we've achieved and he's
going to go on and tell the audience the
things that we've been in and the tv
shows that we've appeared in and our
specials and all of that because in
england if you went up as a compare and
you said that about an act everyone in
the room would turn against them
immediately they'd be like oh he thinks
he's fucking what he's done this he's
done that oh he's been on netflix
special we'll tell you whether he's
funny or not and like you're not gonna
post on these credits oh my god no and
if anyone said a credit on stage in a
comedy club in england the comedian
would be mortified and have to come out
and literally fucking trash themselves
for the first five minutes to get the
audience back on stage so when we come
out here and people are like what do you
want me to say before i bring you out
what credits do you want me to say and
i'm always oh god no don't say anything
tell them i'm you know terrible and
lucky to be here and you know i it may
go one of two ways and just lower that
expectation
it's like who is this fucking guy he's
funny but what's he on letterman yeah
exactly i need i need someone else to
tell me if he's as funny as i think he
is so it took me some time to realize
that i actually have to just enter into
the spirit of things here and boast or
have someone else post on my behalf
before i come out it's because in
england it's just you wouldn't you would
never do it
and also most sets like even if you are
you know a sort of alpha comedian or you
are arrogant or you are playing on your
confidence you still
at the beginning of your set will have
to i think on most occasions like
self-deprecate to try and lower yourself
to
like their level or at least reduce your
status before you start doing your set
but your status is already reduced
you're getting up on stage at night
trying to make strangers laugh yeah but
i just they're already above you
they're sitting there being entertained
by you they need to be told implicitly
before they're willing to give you any
praise it's already a weird piece of
shit
but like it that is so fascinating to me
because i've dated english guys and when
i did it really made it actually because
i had a pathological problem with
self-deprecating yeah because it was
like oh whatever the fuck it was i
thought it made other people more
comfortable i thought of me i i grew up
in a home where i had to make myself
small when you grow up around
narcissists you can't outshine them you
just have to be a piece of shit i got an
a i don't know how like you know like
you have to make yourself small to make
other people feel comfortable and
confident whatever and i carry that
into my life and like well it's cause
i'm an idiot and i'm like stupid and
when you do that it just makes other
people uncomfortable like unless you're
doing it on stage as part of a
performance it's just sort of like
no you're not
no like you're just begging for
compliments and like no one likes it and
one time i was in my therapist office
and um she was uh i said something i was
like because i'm just an idiot and i
called him back and i shouldn't have
called him and she said why do you talk
about to yourself like that and i was
like i was like oh no like i'm i'm a
comedian no it's just like it's funny
she was like
it's not that funny
but i think if you if you said
your piece there in in england
the reaction would be
would be different most people if you're
even if you're you know
very well educated and said i'm an idiot
and self-deprecated in social situations
no one would feel like that was it'd be
like unusual they'd be like yeah okay
correct she hasn't got an ego on her we
can be friends and is it because like
it's so
like i just think of
i guess it's also because like about
what's that people can't take
compliments as well i know and what is
the shame from so is it the shame of
colonialism because there's a deep like
shame
that it feels ancestral trauma
like you there's a is it religious or is
it maybe it tends to be
like oh it's because there's a queen in
the kitchen hierarchy there's no demand
don't shine too bright don't shine too
bright don't get above your station
that's like that's a very big thing
like not ever wanting to look like you
you know
you have any status and to not feel like
you're above anyone because we're just
like so but i talked about you talk posh
so what is that yeah so and with me i'm
like hyper aware of that all the time
like so if you're paid a compliment as
well like that's a polite thing to do is
to torpedo it and to try and you know
you know
sorry just
water onto it
that's the other thing there is a
a
uh
thing
where um i can't i don't know how to
phrase it but
a skepticism about
famous people and the guy that i dated
that was english was like yeah because
all of our heroes when we were kids were
out at his pedophiles
yes and it like broke our heart like was
there like a spree
is that gary glitter gary glitter my mom
was obsessed with glitter but so it was
like what was that sorry i'm pushing
this in your face
um uh what was there like a bunch of
famous people in england like yeah like
that was a reckoning
me too there was something that happened
before the internet
um no it wasn't before the how do you
mean before the end maybe it wasn't like
it was before twitter right no it was
post twitter oh when what yeah i don't
know but it happened
maybe a couple of years before me too
and it was a load of children's
entertainers and musicians and pop stars
a lot of who worked on the bbc a lot of
whom were like very trusted figures and
part of the institution and it turned
out that they were all
um horrendous pedophiles i mean not
there's any other type of people
i read this one
one of the kind ones
i keep trying to abduct children but
they're adults and i can't get it right
i am such a horrendous pedophile
it's just i just i they look very
similar from behind yeah so they were
just pedophiles and was it like photo
like was there like a journal it was
awful like the stuff was like so
terrible and was there like a
whistleblower uh there i can't remember
how the first one of them got outed i
mean one of them the other problem was
that it was like the worst kept secret
in the you know british television was
that this guy was a creep like a lot of
people knew old creepy guy with a cigar
and dark glasses and long white hair
like literally like you know
if you were drawing a paedophile that's
what you would draw and he um was like
doing horrendous things and he was like
a children's entertainer like the host
of top of the paper and then he fell and
then everyone else fell so after that
yeah there was
probably like a distrust of
public figures in the bbc and it was all
like pretty tawdry wild also by the way
like it is amazing to me that the
catholic church does not come up more
it's like
he was involved in the catholic church
we we hear uh tom everything you know we
i feel like we someone's raised catholic
we um
every time a conversation comes up about
predator like we i mean we are in comedy
so we hear a lot of catholic church
jokes so we feel like it's talked about
a lot but in comedy clubs not ever it is
wild to me that nobody cares because it
was boys like no one gives a shit when
you are a priest that molested someone
they send you to rome you go to the
vatican and you have total immunity
because it's the vatican isn't
controlled by the government i hate that
my mind's gone there but
the minute you told me that i thought
now there's another really good nicholas
cage movie which is him going into the
vatican and hunting down a load of dodgy
priests that are hiding out hold on this
is fascinating fascinating i just think
of the world now in nicholas cage films
do you know that he's related to francis
ford coppola yeah and so is jason
schwartzman i did not know that
yeah
don't you feel isn't it weird that you
didn't know that that is weird that i
didn't know that like don't you have
those things where like those two people
are related for no reason i found one
out myself a public figure in the uk who
you are not going to know so i don't
know why i'm dropping his name but
typing i'm related to a man called david
dickinson who is a daytime television
presenter in the uk who has a show
called um
uh what's it called a cache in the attic
which is an antique show and he looks
like a used car salesman he looks like
he's car sales from atlanta and he's got
a very he's an indistinctive style yes
he's an antique dealer yeah
it's like it's one of the weirdest shows
ever his show it's like him like
wandering around with wads of cash
trying to buy like little bits of chins
of old ladies i love that and i think he
did some jail time as well i feel like
he's the talented one in the family
dodgy
uh
business he launches he looks like he's
incredible um
he looks like sylvia berlusconi like he
looks like uh uh is that a can i just
say as well what's also amazing about
him is like
he looks like ron white on american tv i
know he would just like sort of blend in
with quite a lot of people i imagine
like we don't have people that look like
that in england like
no that's a very like
you know i feel like in the sort of
daytime space you have some quite
colorful characters yeah it looks like
joy behar yeah
no you don't that no oh there you are
here we are yeah
that's wild
have you done a 23andme
no you've never done your ancestry test
i have done my ancestry test i did the
show who do you think you are
amazing lisa produces what did you find
out uh so i did it with my father and we
found out
that i have
some family that are welsh and i have an
ancestor who
like i mean they all couldn't be bigger
scumbags if you tried like on one side
of my generation they were all rapists
no he was a he was a syphilitic like
philanderer that gave syphilis to his
wife who then uh ended up dying in a
mental asylum he didn't know he had
syphilis no he did because he gave it to
a lot of people i think don't you think
a woman dying early was actually the
nice thing to do well that's a good way
to spin it
and i should have said that on what i
mean i feel like he was doing them a
favor yeah he had and then i think he
went to jail otherwise they would have
died
and then the other person was involved
in one of the largest massacres of uh
british citizens on british soil
uh for like 300 years and he was the guy
that was like in the movie would
probably have been played by alan
rickman and was like ushering out all
the soldiers and pointing at the rioting
miners and telling them to shoot and
that was my other so there were two
absolute scumbags on both sides of dad's
family well and that's what i'm
descended from well okay well you're not
from a country that destroyed the native
americans and had slavery
i feel like my ancestors were probably a
little shittier than yours yeah but i
imagine i'd probably have a great great
great great great uncle that was on one
of those but if your country hadn't been
so draconian my ancestors wouldn't have
had to come here and kill all the
natives in fairness i'm just not
absolving myself completely because we
only went back so far and i'm sure that
the generation before that yes they were
on the boat it was genghis khan it was
probably the guy that had the cholera
that brought it over for sure
it's just a lot of problematic family
history i'm sorry i'm sorry we are
taking a break from me
flirting with jack whitehall
who has a beautiful wonderful girlfriend
that he's madly in love with uh to tell
you about the venues i'm performing at
that are way smaller than the venues he
performs at i mean it's really a it's a
rough it's a rough pivot it's a bummer
it's a bummer pivot on january 7th i'm
in san diego we're gonna be at the
balboa
theater
always in my dream to perform there and
then i'm gonna be at the kingsbury hall
kingsbury hall in salt lake city that
sounds very english
um january what i don't know wow that
rolled by fast i'm going to be at i'm
going to be in salt lake city in january
also all housewives welcome and then i'm
going to be in viva
las
vegas
i haven't seen you in days because
you've been getting getting your
new apartment which is that looks like
frighteningly close to here
your new place being in the basement is
not too close
your
new apartment looks like sophia lorenz
um powder
and tell me all about it i did get um i
wanted to get new furniture when i moved
so i saved up and i said where can i get
beautiful
plastic gorgeous furniture with a promo
code that'll last me with a discount and
i said articles they have everything
they have like they have really rusted
out they have very modern stuff so i
wanted to do like my living room's all
neutrals and i was like i want a little
bit of color but i don't like love color
it's like this gold bar table set and
it's all like gold
x's that kind of cross over and then
it's like frosted pink top gorgeous
millennial pink delicious they came in
two days they dropped them off right at
my door so nice and literally the
assembly i took one package out and one
package out and i just laid the top on
the table and done you know what promo
code tiger belly
no i did promo i didn't even
support anybody
[Music]
okay i'm moving into my new apartment i
got all my article stuff and i'm gonna
put it out and then show it to you
look
look how easy the article is put
together i did this all by myself
done
article combines the curation of a
boutique
place that sells furniture with the
comfort and simplicity of shopping
online fast affordable shipping is
available across the usa and canada and
is free on orders over 999 dollars and
also i'm sorry i have a bruise on my
knee that it's not from what you think
article is offering our listeners 50 off
your first purchase of 100 or more go to
article.com whitney and the discount
will be automatically applied at
checkout that's article.com whitney to
get 50 off your first purchase and 100
or more
speaking of more more more
more
we have a really fun game for this oh i
cannot wait for ya phoria is this sex
lube company it's not even lube it says
it's a it's an arousal oil sex lube i
don't like that word it's like secretary
versus you know
assistant versus chief we say chief of
staff are you're blindfolding me right
now yep yep you guys they're
blindfolding me don't do it too tight
okay
so can someone explain narrate what's
happening please emily all right because
people are assume people listen to a
podcast we are
blindfolding whitney okay do a little
game with her we're gonna see if whitney
can figure out which one of these
products is our wonderful sponsor
we're playing a game called guess the
loop
we're going to see if we can figure out
which one is our wonderful sponsor for
ya and which one is not
lou wait what are we putting it on it's
on are we putting it directly on your
table
[Laughter]
wait where is it going can i hold on can
i have a little
no we're talking so this is the first
now i am getting aroused i'm putting
three plates in front of you
you are going to feel with your digits
your fingers mm-hmm
they're attached to your hands they're
called phalanges and you need to guess
which is our wonderful sponsor okay
first one
put your fingers right in there okay
do you think that's what do you think
that is am i allowed to spell it i mean
smell it no yeah oh yeah you could smell
it yeah because am i allowed to
masturbate with it yeah put in your lips
do whatever you want it's up to you now
hold on i'd i'd love to see you
masturbate with this one that's
definitely not it it's pepperminty she
says no to that what did you think it
was
like a peppermint oil like toothpaste or
peppermint oil you're close but it was
pepto-bismol oh oh my god ah i can't
believe i didn't come
i love okay can i drink it there's
another plate in front of you reach out
and oh
sorry okay there's another plate in
front of you reach out put your finger
down move your hand down exactly
okay
it's very cold did you put this in the
fridge
no this is definitely not a that is uh
what is the word abrasive okay now how
does that feel feel it what do you think
ah
okay there we go
yeah
do you feel like you could have the best
orgasm or sex you've ever had it was the
third one yeah it was the third third
one
now that we have fourier imagine the
best orgasm or sex you've ever had now
imagine it could be even better with
products that were designed to naturally
enhance sexual pleasure i have such a
sexy voice and give you access to
i can't read that word
bigger
is using all-natural and plant-based
ingredients to intensify sexual pleasure
and relieve discomfort there's cbd in
this used together look how beautiful
this bottle is used together for ya's
awakening arousal oil and sex oil are
the perfect combo for peak pleasure so
yes you have my permission to try this i
fully endorse you to go ahead and treat
yourself to more deeper fuller pleasure
wherever you can find it as often as
possible and you can start with a bottle
of phoria i'm holding it up it is classy
it is chic
four is offering a special deal for our
listeners you get 20 off your first
order by visiting for you f o r i a
wellness dot com slash whitney or use
the code whitney for checkout that's
fourierwellness.com
forward slash whitney for twenty percent
off your first order i recommend trying
their awaken arousal oil and sex oil you
will thank me later back to jack
whitehall
do you worry about like your dms and
stuff
my dm's like do you just worry that
you're a target because you're so famous
i worry
like i worry more
i'm worried about um like jokes and
material that i've done that's out there
in the ether that you did before yeah
yeah but why
because you did it yeah i know but i've
already had it it's like wearing a
shitty shirt 10 years ago yeah it was
cool back then yeah i don't tell you it
was funny back then it's not anymore
yeah fine
i had a joke that i did
about a friend of mine who was of
restricted height
an elf
no that's not that's not the way yes it
is it's
a person that is
as my father would say not a tall man
imagine let's go with that not at all
man and it was a true story about me and
this friend of mine at college and we
were
rather inebriated we were at a night out
and we went to the bathroom and it is
like you know not even embellished at
all this is genuine also to be fair
you're too tall sorry
you're yes you're weirdly tall yeah yeah
so
you know what i mean he could have just
been he's probably a normal height yeah
yeah
you're the freak in this
i am yeah exactly and i had to um
assist him because all the cubicles were
full because i think people were
probably doing drugs in them and i had
to help him use a urinal oh yeah
i shook him he elbowed me and then i
dropped him and
so i told a whole story about that
and with his permission he was like yeah
it was hilarious
and then i told it like 10 years ago and
then it got repeated on the bbc and two
people complained and then it was two
people two people out of the millions
that loved it yeah so you're going to
focus on those two nerds
those by the way your two ex-girlfriends
[Laughter]
two girls that you did not date them and
they're pissed off yeah
or like
russell brand
it was russell brown russell brandon
benedict cumberbatch who called him to
complain about you because you were
taking too many jobs i was taking too
many jobs and they just complained about
that routine and then it was but it's
just gonna get better and it was yeah it
blows over it blows over so quickly also
thanks for the advertising now more
people are gonna go watch it like he's
hilarious yeah and that's not offensive
it is what it is he's a comedian he's
supposed to say great comedians are
supposed to say crazy shit it is our job
to take you through the haunted house
and say the things nobody else will say
yeah that's our job yeah do you want to
come to a comedy show and just hear a
bunch of stuff you hear all day at work
the idea that it's like oh my gosh you
said the thing no one can say and like
we let the tension out and like the
whole point is smart people know it's a
joke yeah
and the reason we tell is because it's
offensive that's the whole point yeah
but then yeah i guess it's just because
when it gets reported out of context to
people that don't go to comedy clubs
then nobody cares
nobody cares richard pryor talked about
hitting his wife in the face and setting
himself on fire smoking crap yeah
we're good
and he's thought it was the greatest
community of all time
what you need to hit your little friend
yeah in the face call smokey crack you
just need to go so far
it is wild though it also it just pisses
me off because you're it's clear that
you're a kind person with that isn't a
sociopath so people feel like they can
be i feel like people are like he should
know about it's like where is someone if
someone's an asshole and it's always
been natural they're fine yeah you know
what i mean yeah yeah it's like look
like david tell they're just like that's
what he does yeah yeah whereas like you
they're like he but he also
i've seen him with his dad and he really
loves his dad and he shouldn't do
something he shouldn't say you know what
i mean yeah but are you able to not care
but getting better at not caring the the
one where in it blew up the most for me
just after i'd said a joke and i and
after that i definitely changed my act a
bit and
was self-centered myself more was when i
made a joke on a tv show
um
about the queen
with it was a show with called the big
fat quiz of the year was like jimmy carr
and russell brown and noel fielding and
all these people and it was it's a
really fun show and it goes on for hours
and hours and again it's one of those
ones where you get a bit drunk
and it was the year of the queen's um
jubilee
pageant where they had all those boats
going down the river
and
very strange and she stopped offensive
to me yeah that your tax dollars go to a
jubilee yes
and so and well yes and the only plus
side of it should be that you're allowed
to make jokes
yeah and she stood up for the whole
thing and all the newspapers were asking
why she'd stood up and an old lady
shouldn't have been stood for that long
and then the following morning prince
philip went to hospital with a urinary
infection and i didn't even make the
joke i just pointed out some pieces of
information that it was their
anniversary she didn't want to sit down
and he ended up in hospital with a
urinary infection and allowed the
audience to put together assumptions as
to what they might have been getting up
to for their anniversary
they both got hookers that night
and it was like fucking honestly like
it's so strange that that's still a
taboo that by the way people were
to imply that a
400 year old woman is still having sex
yes and that that they're still sexual
because the opposite would be ageist
so if you say like well because they
never have sex it'd be like that's
ageist i think it's cool to imply that a
woman of that age would still be a
sexual being in sexual attraction i wish
i'd said that in response
which i didn't i just like being friends
with me comes in very handy i am good at
daily mail front page of complaints no
one is better at gaslighting them yeah
this is where i shine you got to call me
because it's like just be like oh so if
i didn't make the joke i'm implying that
she's not sexual because women after a
certain age just aren't they just
they're unattractive
yeah you know what i mean like being so
much better than just
silence comedians never run their
apologies by me it's why we've lost half
of them yeah
every time i see the apology in the
notes app i'm like could you have just
texted i would have fixed this i would
have put in the apology somewhere in the
words i'm sorry
and you'd be out of this mess
and you'd have your life back
like just like basically guys run it by
other guys like what do you think of
this apology yeah she was good
she wasn't so hot i would have done it
like
please can i do a pass on this
i never want to stop talking to you i
know you have to go um you don't but you
do i know i'm holding you too long but
i'm really obsessed with you and i feel
like you don't live here so i really
need to
keep you cuz i'm gonna ask a couple
things we always ask on the podcast i'm
genuinely curious
um number one
uh red flags i always ask about red
flags on the show yeah of like what are
red flags and potential mates
when you're dating you're not you're
with someone but what are red flags and
people it can be anything from
has a chain wallet to
follows porn stars on instagram to like
if a girl is coming up to you flirting
with you like what's the red flag if you
go to a couple dates with a girl
she name drops other people she's data
russell brand
she
i love russell he knows that
uh i just don't want to talk about
meditation i'll see you the scarf is is
it are you hot or cold why are you going
to start for the tank top you got to
pick one um
oh well one
test that i like is
do they like with nell and i which is my
favorite movie i'm sorry with nell and i
nell
oh you've never seen it
with nell who wrote it with us
bruce robinson richard e grant forming
my favorite movie of all time okay we
never have to worry about if if you're
the if i'm the one that got away
i'm like what the fuck is this with nail
and it's a good acid test i think of
whether someone's going to be on board
it's an english cult movie
and if you hate that or you're all
offended by it it follows unemployed
actors so it's a horror movie
they need a holiday they obtain the key
to a country cottage in the lake
district belonging to with nails you
need to watch this movie i'm good no
you don't even really like it i feel
like i should watch them wrong missy
again
i will i will actually
i could never get him to laugh uh i will
watch this i will watch this that would
be my video all i see is monty
insistently demands they have sex
i love a non-consensual sex scene
in a comedy
maybe it wouldn't get made brings me
back to my my uh early days of doing
stand-up
the nostalgia
i should have thought of something
better than that but like has any girl
you've ever dated seen it though
no i've just never shown them because
i'm fearful that no one likes it other
than me you know what a red flag is a
guy saying you have to have seen what's
name and it's a terrible answer bollocks
that's a terrible answer no it was a
good one no
because here's what i'm saying i think
they do they like torturing animals that
would be a red flag for me those are so
so fast
there we are yeah that's better than the
withdrawal answer
you meet those people stop pretending
you're running cool circles
stop returning your girlfriend most of
my friends hunt foxes
that's true foxes in england are like
are like
squirrels
no we have squirrels as well
that's a really terrible analogy
i was like can i let that slide and i'm
like no because there will be people in
england that watch and listen to this
and
[Laughter]
that's not true no sure there are like
that
neither of us know if that's not no but
it just don't sounds wrong it sounds
right it sounds close it sounds close i
just found out the other day a billion
birds die a year flying into windows
it sounds like a lot it sounds like a
little too much i don't know i said i
was like it doesn't sound right i'm not
a birdologist i know nothing about this
but it doesn't sound right yeah but i
guess you get a couple of flocks that
knocks out a few bunch of ones
yeah but also um
ireland doesn't have snakes
yeah i would say that's probably they
don't it is true that is true i've
looked into this a lot yeah so i'm just
saying anything's possible less less
amazing that one than the billion birds
like easier to believe that wasn't
trying to compare them wasn't ranking
them you did that you did that yeah
that's true but no snakes because it's
an island and you're an island so who
knows what fucking animals you don't
have
scotland does not have giraffes
is that true yeah
i'm sure it has simple
oh yeah well yeah
but so ireland doesn't have a zoo
it doesn't have a snake in a zoo
we're talking about surely snakes in
their natural habitat
in the natural habitat no yeah there is
a reptile there's a guy that's got a
snake
there's a kid
they're not running around anywhere no
by the way they're slithering
dude snakes are fucking wild how fast
they can move i have uh rattlesnakes
okay but if you see one that can run
it's a lizard
[Laughter]
i don't want to get old david
attenborough yeah i get why i get why
people get mad at your jokes yeah
because you attack women and you're
fucking a bully you're a bully and i see
it now i defended you and now i'm truly
not defending you next time next time
you
make fun of a hogwarts i'm gonna come
for you
so there is a zoo in
uh
ireland and they do have snakes uh
apparently according to this website but
i don't believe everything i see on the
internet so let's roll that i'm already
fucking sure giraffes returned to the
edinboro zoo after 15 years
oh and there's pandas in edinburgh zoo
famous says bbc.com they sent the
pedophile
monthly
yes and i've been to a friend of mine
they sent pandas to
to scotland to mate
because it's the center of teenage
pregnancies in europe
do you want to weigh in emily's the
panda expert really yeah i just i know a
lot about pandas do you yeah it's i i
mean hopefully they'll succeed in the
breeding program it's very difficult
because they want to extinct themselves
they do yes they don't want to be here
anymore and we're forcing them to be
here mm-hmm
that's sad well they're a weird yeah
they're not weird they just don't
they're done no no animal wants to be in
a zoo it's not just they don't but they
don't want to be in the wild yeah they
do you don't know that i know for sure
they've never seen footage of them
naturally without people filming them
like of how happy they are there you've
only seen weirdos chasing them around
they're always alone they're always
alone they're fertile one day that
doesn't mean they're not happy i'm alone
and i'm happy i'm more i'm never more
miserable than i'm with somebody if it
weren't for the conservation efforts
they'd be gone and they want to be gone
yeah but conservation efforts are not
real yes they are we they're not even on
the intended okay you don't like dogs so
you don't get to work
we said we weren't going to tell people
that emily did stand up twice in one of
her sets she opened with i don't like
dogs
and she's like i don't understand why
that didn't kill like what wow she's
like i only like pandas because they
just want to extinguish and we're going
to bring that out to the star of
clifford
we think that that's appropriate read
the room
i'm friends with um someone that owns
woburn safari
and went there and got to look at the
new draft exhibit up close and it was
magical the giraffe exhibit
what's the giraffe exhibit it's just a
bunch of drafts in a oh okay okay okay
what else would it what would it be what
wouldn't it be for me that sounded a bit
more morbid like if an animal is
exhibited it
makes me think that it's been stuffed
the animal
paddock paddock yeah no i guess it is an
exhibit isn't it but exhibit makes me
think of art it makes me think of
something
i think animals are art yeah
so their gods are
they aren't godzilla
god's taxidermy where are you on
religion where am i on religion yeah
do you pray uh no i went to a
very christian school set up for sons of
the clergy where we were you know
singing hymns every morning and
bible classes and all of that so that
put me
oh i was the only one they never went
anywhere near i feel like the older i
was like i feel like i'm not like wasn't
i'm like i'm agnostic i'm atheist i'm
this but like we all have our own
religions you know what i mean whether
it's like working out or like
you know whatever the fuck we do work et
cetera but i do find that i'm now
doing this thing where whenever i want
something or something's going badly i
all of a sudden i'm like
god like
just in case he's real i just wanna i
don't wanna i don't go in for that i
always think that i'd just be good at
the gates of heaven as like i'm quite a
good blagger i can get into a splagger
like sort of you know
sort of charm my way into a
charm
no you can i think i'd be like i get a
look on the list and i'd be able to this
isn't this is
the box
this isn't we don't know that we
we don't know that maybe we go through
the pearly gates of heaven and there is
a lady painted like a smurf pulling a
dildo out of her ass and spraying
chocolatey water all over the crowd
pitching the tv show you want to do it
from that place they're not going to buy
it
[Laughter]
your best friend works there he's not
going to buy it stop trying to get that
idea out there
the impersonator one's good
with your buzz pitching the ideas that
are makable yeah that's unmaking uh do
you have any habits that you want to
break
do i have any habits that i want to
um besides lying about your nose picking
do you pick your different that's not a
habit that's just a group i do really
bad do you really bad and kovid has
really made that but have you ever
watched your notes i got fired from a
job because i was picking my nose i was
serving tables and picking my notes well
yeah that's pretty gross that's fair
that's fair i don't know i'm not
disputing it 100 they were in the right
i should have been fired on the spot and
i was that's um it was gross so i have
some pretty lousy hygiene
yeah um which weirdly they were fine
with which by the way it kind of is okay
i wish i could just part this again but
like
that's quite a big butthole
i'm like we didn't want to enter into
this riff i should have just like means
you either have a giant dick or i have a
tiny bottle anything that
sorry
i'm not being weeded that's a big that
would be
not with your finger in it are you
choking if it's just there
yeah yeah if i pull down my pants down
and expose myself to you obviously there
would be other things in play that would
make it really problematic but if that
was my butthole you'd be like whoa this
guy's had a heart
if it was pretend if you put your finger
in it it could get that big with your
finger in it it would feel kind of like
you were fingering a young model
if you needed that sensation that badly
yeah like dan men says the funniest joke
you know dan he's like he's more of a
writer now he's on bojack horseman and
he writes for big mouth and he's like
just the funniest he has one of the
greatest jokes ever he does he's like
one-liners and we kind of came up
together and now he's like an adult and
has a family and just writes on shows
because he's not a psychopath that tours
around the country in his late 30s and
uh he has like just brilliant jokes he
goes um you know it'd be really
confusing if you were performing
abortion and someone ran in and yelled
abort abort
like his mind is just
fucking annoyingly incredible and he
goes um
mr joker he's like you know there's
something called the stranger
where
you like sit on your hand until your
hand gets yeah yeah and then jerk
yourself off and it feels like a
stranger is jerking yeah i should i i
went in really quick knowing what that
was i probably should have suffered all
that oh yes
yes oh this is a stranger you say let's
stop there
comedians i don't know what the fucking
dolphin is in the strawberry shortcake
and all this shit like we know we're
good we're adults here
and
i'm sitting on my hand for one afternoon
right now yeah
and he goes i like to sit on my dick and
jerk myself off so it feels like i'm
being jerked off by a stranger
it doesn't feel like another person is
doing it it feels like you're getting
wanked off by like a dying man yeah
not that i've heard which is not no it's
just kind of like for that to be
someone's last yeah like on their
deathbed the last thing they did please
can i joke you off that would be kind of
amazing an amazing gesture i don't like
that would like go out with a bang yeah
but in order to
uh jerk yourself to tumescence you would
need
at least some you know give in there so
you would have sensation in the arm
again if i'm talking about it in too
much detail now
[Applause]
because i just want to see how this pans
out because i really i don't know i'm
just saying it doesn't feel like a
stranger so if anyone was planning on
doing it just think it through who are
you trying to convince me i don't know i
don't know i don't know who this is this
feels like a youth thing this feels like
you need to call your friend from the
urinal and just apologize it's just you
know
you've done nothing wrong
in america whatever that is isn't
perverse
you're the like least disgusting
comedian in america
because i you're the most wholesome once
at school sat on my arm
masturbated sure
why did you have to say it was at school
why do you have to bring that into it
why can't you just say one time i did it
because i didn't do his grown man
okay but at school could be fourth grade
it could be second grade
yeah yeah i mean
i know but
at school there were other people that
could do it but i guess england you say
like at school like i would never say
that sorry like when i was in school i
used to masturbate with my numb hand i
just like when i was younger yes
school makes it like hot it's kinky and
like forbidden it does it makes it weird
it's like i picture you like in a
uniform like with harry potter glasses
yeah it makes it like naughtier
okay i know i'm gonna let you out
eventually
um what is your definition of love
uh
my definition of love it's a nightmare
question i know it's such a nightmare i
know um
i can give you my nail and i we're
always trying to like every guest i
always ask their definition of it and i
have some very good answers can you help
me well mine i said and i think it was
my second special i said um love uh my
definition of love is being willing to
die for someone that you yourself want
to kill
being able to dive somewhat yeah that's
being willing to die for something like
if someone broke and if we were in love
if someone broke into my house like to
kill us and held up a gun i'd be like
stop like let me can i do it let's just
let me do it if we're doing this anyway
you know like and then some people say
like it's
when you
uh like bringing out the best in you
like when you're the best for you
yeah when you're
waiting to put someone first and
prioritize that without strings attached
without strings unconditionally put them
in front like how did you know you were
in love
i mean i've seen her i know i would say
i would say
i would say a combination of those two
things my willingness and desire to put
her
needs in front of mine that also makes
me feel good and comfortable and
uh
contented it doesn't feel like an
obligation it's like brings me pleasure
to do good things nice things for you
yes i want
have you succeeded at that at all
yeah on most occasions what are you
gonna do about if you just as someone
that has been all around the world yeah
where would you honeymoon
where would we honeymoon where would you
yeah like what would be someone that's
been everywhere
yeah like if i was her i'd be a little
annoyed because it's like you've been
everywhere everywhere like i want to go
somewhere with you that no one has gone
that you've never been before
where would we go like somewhat like we
both like
adventure and activity so someone where
we could go and
you know we're like to panga
[Music]
yeah to banga there's a lot of hiking
trails around here you're gonna come to
my house for your honeymoon yeah she's
gonna be pretty bad
hey you might have to vacation no no
come on
we might have to do a house switch you
can be in london no but like seriously
like as i'm obsessed with someone that's
been everywhere like where
is what is your favorite destination
you've been to i know this is dorky
question but i love shitload most people
do not get to travel everywhere yeah
because there's certain places i went to
the maldives okay i went to the maldives
morty's is incredible
i think you can skip it really i think
it can be skipped
it's amazing i'm one and done three days
and you're done that's the thing but
it's a long way to go for three days
it's a very long flight no one goes
through today and you're on like
lufthansa yeah hmm yeah there's no
mileage you're not getting points it was
driving me nuts and uh and you get there
i stayed where'd you stay can i ask uh
st regis probably
i say jilly lincoln fushi which is like
amazing amazing i was like i'm going to
go all out i never vacation i had just
been running like the roseanne show it
was a little stressful and so i was like
i deserve this i'm taking someone
i'm editing i just finished editing a
movie i'm gonna do the notes there and
also i think that for like when you're
super busy and as someone that's so
addicted to like i don't like emails
just sitting there and not responding it
just i'd rather just even if i'm on
vacation respond to them so i don't
think about it all day so i have to go
to a different time zone so that it's
like my day
everyone's sleeping in the states yeah
so i'm don't get emails till 9 pm at
night and then i can just respond to
them when i've already had a couple
drinks and i'm fine so go
it's so beautiful i did not grow up with
money i did not grow up with vacations
like this we went to fort lauderdale
like on a fancy trip and
we're in this what do you call a villa
above water villa yeah and if you get
there and it's the most beautiful thing
ever you're like this is a screensaver i
can't believe i'm here the water is like
bath water it's stunning there's little
sharks and shit swimming around it's
perfect instagram nailed it in the
algorithm likes killing it and then you
lay down at night and the water
is hitting the bottom of the villa
and you don't
i don't like that no no no
they use this in some cultures to
torture people
into speaking
and i'm like go to the front desk i was
like
the water and they were like
we can't really turn that no
and i'm like can you make the villa
higher they're like
no we can't like the amount of money i'm
paying here all night i'm just hearing
so i had to like take lunesta and like
drink my and i couldn't sleep
yeah i can see how that would be
maddening
but i f like and i'm not taking the side
of the oh
you take inside of this ocean
are you going to defend the people right
now i'm just going to kill you in a
heartbeat the ocean would not be on your
side of the brochure like if
ocean noise was going to be an issue in
the brochure as you would say it was
below the fucking deck the water wasn't
against the thing no no but i just
it well i didn't think it was a pirate
ship yeah when i got there i didn't know
how high the water was how do you how do
you have it established i thought the
water was getting lower but it's not
it's getting higher yeah the glaciers
yeah so the photos they have are
pre-melted glaciers yeah yeah yeah and i
didn't know mine was a bit higher i
think i was on one on on a higher set of
stills well you do maybe you can do
studio movies
i don't know what to tell you
you got one with it was on short stilts
i got it's the five star one yeah that
was a comical amount of money yeah a
night
the mango smoothies were 18 yeah and i
couldn't sleep yeah
did it have the little uh
like glass floor so in the in the
bathroom
which is a which was by the way you
fogged up fucked up because it feels
like you're shitting onto the car that
was
it was foggy was it yeah mine was clear
as day so you could see everything
down below you were higher yeah i was i
exactly i could barely see it because
you were saying
needs to look at the ocean when they're
shitting this asshole
like how you know i know it's a bit just
weird and you could see like you know
stingrays and coral and all this beauty
and then you're literally just shitting
into it from a height as well well not
in your case but from my case
where is all my shit going in there yeah
am i shitting in his house i also
traveled all the way there and got all
the way to the maldives for this like
romantic getaway and walked out onto my
um
the like
porch of that that the room and in the
room next to me there was a guy who i
know from london who's like a friend of
my sister's plumber who's like very loud
like bummer and he's in the thing next
to me gotta get out and he's swimming
around
there waving up at me through the glass
floor when i'm having it this piers
morgan
yeah that you can't
if you see someone you know on vacation
you you have to move then you're going
to move villas yeah
move islands that's a nightmare do you
know that in the maldives there's a
trash island an island that's only their
trash really
i would beg them to go see that one's a
lot stupid to stay on
i think it's a lot quieter yeah a lot
quieter i'd rather stay there i'd rather
make like remember in labyrinth the lady
that had the trash on her back i'd
rather make a little trash house that
didn't make noise so that's the other
thing it's like for me
vacation is your a bed that's quiet so
i'd i'd rather go to
pensacola at this point new zealand i'd
like to go there for honeymoon yeah on
the south island where it's all doesn't
it seem kind of true
like
like we got it the yeah well that's the
only problem with new zealand
it does look a bit like scotland
yeah
and sheep which there's a lot of there i
feel like i might get all the way there
i got it
what about
bora bora
for your honeymoon where is brooke near
tahiti like pollen french polynesia
um
yeah there's a do you know about that
before is there's a beach called ibiza
which is what i thought you were
referencing is it a beta or ibiza
don't talk to me like that
um you know what do you know that in
french polynesia there is a hotel called
the brando and it's because it's it's
marlon brando's island what yes it's
it's marlon brando's island i'm obsessed
with like looking at resorts on the
internet and never visiting them but
like it's his hotel
isn't that crazy that is insane marlin
it's called the brando who is related to
um dennis leary
i have to google that yeah who's related
to conan o'brien yeah so that all three
of them are related to each other i feel
like brando was
fine as an actor
can we just agree
that we're pushing it here yeah
if you look back now it's a little broad
it's a little much yeah
but people may say that about nicolas
cage in 10 years time i say that now
i just feel like
like we say things or like this and then
to seem cool and like we know something
we're like he's brilliant and then you
look back and you're like okay he's
wonderful yeah
but i mean
was it of its time
like you watched some of those old
english actors those nights
this is your defense
about your friend
brando looking back now it's
this joke might not be funny now but
brando's work not that good now we've
seen that laurence olivier see how that
lands old like like recordings in
lawrence i'm sorry jimmy stewart you're
like dude yeah take it
to compare to yeah and now we have like
ed norton
i don't know i don't know why he's the
first person that came to mind yeah look
at this so look at this you should go
here
related
to no he is that's to graham norton no
way they are
i mean all nortons are what is that what
do you know groundhog and edward norton
it's like
this is almost like you're i drove your
myself lie
[Laughter]
well you bought the dennis leery one and
that was just am i sold on this well i
we bring up dedicatory pretty much every
uh podcast for random reasons hawaii
no hawaii hawaii is great it's just very
alohas and mahi mahi after a week of
that you're just like i need something
busy it's very busy and you're going to
run into all your agents that you fired
you're going to run your life any of
them yet why not
no because things are going well
okay last thing we're going to do
because i'm so charmed by you i know i'm
supposed to talk about clifford and you
know it's on you've already seen it
whatever
um uh
i
loved it in your show oh
thank you that you eat pickled eggs oh
have you ever eaten one of them before
no
so i thought in your honor i would try
one before we go i had to do to the end
of the show yeah um so
uh it's so genius to me thank you that
also when you were on that agatha
christie island you were just drinking
milk
was that was that what that was yeah i
was just drinking milk that is so funny
do you want to hear something else about
that agatha christie island when we were
there the week after we left no dead
body turned up in the water for real and
there's a murder investigation
this is he went to the agatha christie
island where there was a
like a clue like
real
like actors reenactors doing like a
murder mystery who done it uh who done
it on the island agatha christie wrote
all of these books and then the week
later we leave and the body turns up and
there's a load of
like police investigation into an actual
murder was it one of the people that you
have played the game with oh my god
maybe they got just carried away
maybe it was the winston churchill look
alike
no maybe he pitched up there
it was the mage she was always yeah she
was over over acting she was brown doing
it that was
hey your acting is a little bit like
marlon brandon
thank you
okay so why do you love pickled eggs
right you love them for real or is this
a joke uh i
i don't mind a pickled egg but you were
eating in the car with your dad yeah it
was so funny i like eating i like i do i
i quite like
quite gross food yeah it's pretty so i
love pickles my favorite food is pickles
and eggs separately do you know what i
mean yeah so you might you might you
should not do this no i think you should
go for it
they're they're pretty punchy though but
you were eating them in the car with
your dad like very casually like a snake
yeah but i sort of need it with
something else
like a snake you were like no problem
what do you mean like what i had
i had it with uh yeah that helps um i'd
had it with um
no oh yeah extra victory pour some wine
on the pickled egg that'll do it okay
i've never had one of these and i always
see them and i'm like
that is so my style of food
something here with this other fork
is it with double food i hate two forks
and i'm just gonna i'm just gonna i'm so
[Music]
but is it fresh like is it is it fresh
that's the least fresh thing i've ever
seen in my life i feel like this these
were probably laid in the 80s i feel
like these are like rations like this is
like what they may have this may have
been an egg that came out of a chickens
like men in the sea
yeah like this was like for men in
normandy yeah yeah yeah what are the
ones that you buy then
to be honest that one that i was eating
was quite a bougie one it's fake it'd
have been like flavor no they've been
flavored with nice pickles
nice pickles oh like with some nice
herbs no
hold on this is it's all the same
vinegar water beet juice sugar salt
spices they don't say what kind did it
say what in general old spice like they
don't even say
uh acids citric acid potassium surveyed
sodium benzene can take contains eggs
yeah no shit
contains eggs contains eggs
at the end as well yeah it's just that's
the final thought yeah just fyi that
makes eggs and it starts with eggs as
well oh i don't want to eat it now i'm
feeling like i feel like because now you
know it contains eggs
yeah but i now feel like i'm just
eating like a chicken abortion
amish valley these are amish i know
they're amish eggs yeah and they're
known for their great decisions yeah
they're known for their awesome culinary
swings yeah they're known for their
michelin star
do you have amish people in england no
no amish people just squirrels
um
the actually the squirrels actually
wiped out the amish did you know that
squirrels the sarah silverman joke about
this they hide their nuts and they can't
remember where they
hid them and that's how trees get
planted
if you don't cry you're a psychopath
i'm not now i feel like i'm not gonna do
this if i thought you would be like yes
and just be deep throating them
i thought this was like something you
ate regularly
yeah i mean i have eaten them in the
past
okay i'm going to eat a pickled egg
because i do this is the type of way i'm
going to get you a napkin where are they
i have plenty of napkins but a paper
towel because i bet you're going to spit
it out well then i'll spit it on this
feather you will because it's not quite
as bad as you think it's i think this is
the type of food i would really
appreciate it's going to smell bad i
might have to leave i'm going to you
know that's why the smell's over because
it's out now emily why do you have to
make this about you i've been over your
gag
okay well
good you should know it maybe you'll get
a boyfriend
[Music]
oh sorry don't be mad one two three
it's not gonna be as bad as you think
see just get over the initial shock
and it will grow on you because it
eventually just becomes an egg honestly
it just tastes like a hard boiled egg
yeah it does yeah honestly but should we
microwave like if you microwave them i
would not microwave why not it would be
very offensive to the amish but then
it's just a horrible though they didn't
want it it was a vintage vintage
vintage
we drink old wine we drink all it's not
that if you're in a jam i just don't
know why you'd eat it if you could just
make a regular egg like you have
something went horribly wrong well
anyway that's what i was on here to
promote
i was really trying to get more people
to eat pickled eggs in america it's by
the way your backup plan you're going to
be back in place this is my backup plan
i have got into bed
with the amish valley products
uh corporation and we're yeah we're just
trying to get the word out there clooney
has a tequila george clooney has tequila
whitehall has amish valley product
pickled beet eggs
out ryan reynolds
i'm coming for you
yes indeed jar bollocks
[Laughter]
oh
every comedian yeah you gotta have a bat
you gotta have a brand you gotta have
this is my retirement plan
no more movies required for me
you know to get in shape out of the gym
i'll be able to own all of tapanga did
you know that you stopped flying off the
shelves uh larry the cable guy makes 370
thousand dollars a year on beef jerky
alone really
well there's you know
he puts his name on beef jerky it's in
the grocery store yeah
and what's donna's done and i could have
jack whitehall's pickled bollocks
look
i i if you want me to be your manager
i'll consider it yeah
salty bollocks i could call it and it
could be my pickled eggs
i would buy them
would anyone else is the question
maybe i should pickle bollocks salty
bollocks why not salty but they're not
that they're they're sour bollocks are
they sour bullets
sour bollocks works as well there
sauerbollocks bitterbollocks
bitterbollocks i don't know where the
amish value gonna be
we don't know yeah we do we steal from
them yeah we still yeah we steal their
idea yeah and then they get no credit
what they they didn't come up with
[Laughter]
what are they gonna you know what i mean
they won't know what are they gonna like
get in their carriage and get on the
oregon trail by the time they get us we
will have already made a billion
dollars they're the best people to steal
from because they'll never hear about it
i'll never hear about it they won't even
hear about this playing do something
should never get on the internet still
still maybe they're rum springer
oh that's right they get on the rum
springer that's a good rum springer
bollocks and the rum springer bollocks
yeah that's pretty good it's very good
clifford
the jonas roast are you excited
i'm excited it airs like now right the
giants manage yeah this morning you're
on it and i haven't seen it who else is
on it um
lilly singh pete davidson wow john
legend jesus
the jonas brothers
it's worth watching have you seen just
to watch nick jonas do stand up at the
end he's he's funny
right it's
it's worth watching to the end for that
he is so
but by the time you've gotten slammed
even if it's not a professional comedian
to just see like
i don't know you're like rooting for the
person in a way yeah yeah and the wives
absolutely trash them
he is sophie's very funny hot and that's
not even my type of thing yeah like that
song i got you in chains is a
very good
it's a banger i went to see them at the
hollywood bowl are you friends with them
nope
not after the roast was it awkward
no i i think i
probably
pitched it a little coarser than some of
the others and also i wasn't married to
them so you get away with less their
wives did yeah they they did great
sophie turner she was very funny
and then who's the other one oh she he's
yeah he's married to her right yeah yeah
did she do us yeah he did she did she
did a good bit she trashed him
i'm pouring my last glass of wine as i
let you go
good luck tonight thank you very much at
the rose battle i'm gonna get destroyed
face time me in any prep yeah i'll
facetime you this is where i shine yeah
when i need your assistance in slamming
these
people um
but also there's something can you do
like uh
i left harder and animated dog
yes
yeah uh you're you're
uh
uh this job i hate this job and i just
did a movie with an animated dog
i hate this gig and i just had to do do
a gig with the jonas brothers wives yeah
like if you bring it back slamming
yourself you know what i mean no one can
ever get you yeah the self-deprecation
yeah
i'll just join in with the roasting of
myself
a self-righteous
like if you kind of deprecate like
houses i mean that's what you do anyway
you know if you sit on your arm for long
enough you can make it feel like someone
else is roasting you
you know if you sit on your bollocks
long enough they get pickles
it's so stupid
i don't know why you said yes to this
but i'm very grateful that you did
i'm very grateful that i podcasts matter
more in america they do yeah
i think i've ever done a podcast in
america yeah that's weird never get
asked so it was very nice to be honest
yeah because no one thinks he'll say yes
but i'm delusional as i said i think i'm
part of your family yeah so i was like
he's gonna do his sister's podcast he
can't say no
we have the same father
like what kind of asshole is not gonna
do his own sister's podcast like i fully
think we're like
for like in a family yeah
you're taking him on the road next you
got so fucked like i my dad dies i watch
your show and get like emotionally
attached to you you're like i wouldn't
be coming soon so
winnie coming's like things were like
what a nightmare
that's such a funny thing to have me
bonded to you and you like don't know me
at all
can you imagine what a nightmare that
would be this whitney coming sponsored
i'm calling me i don't know what to do
[Laughter]
i'm not equipped to deal with this it's
so funny to have me as like as your
stalker
you don't even like me but you can't
like
blow me off because i'm the loud mouth
just having to roofie pickled eggs and
slices like why isn't jack texting me
now like i'll just like tell him
why is that so funny to me god the idea
of having another
person in your field
like your stalker being someone that's
like a
comedian
[Laughter]
so you sound like an asshole if you say
i'm talking like you can't tell anyone
no because you'll sound crazy also okay
you're selling a liar
well now we have these tapes though so i
think you know but they'll be like well
she was joking
like she was joking
she was you know what a joke is
like you're
really in a jam
like i've got you right where i watch
you
drop to your house
and then people are going to be like
yeah jack is saying you're stalking him
i'm like
we did one podcast together he like i
don't know just i got him a car serve it
like i didn't even
[Laughter]
one time about my dad
well i joked about it it's weird
comedians don't get jokes these days
i am these very awkwardly
is there anything else
uh do you have any pickled onions no i
don't i was gonna say something wild i
would say i do have my panties
you pickle those
i'm saying i don't know if you're done
but i do have the song i'm wearing
if you just want the experience just
don't ride elephants good night
thank you for watching this program
[Music]
uh
[Applause]